[Music]
is this rolling
probably not oh boy
hi my name is markiplier and this might
be the saddest i've ever been
you know all those videos where i was
crying this might be sadder than that i
don't know if you can hear the sound
but my computer is literally melting
itself alive
also you may notice that i'm holding my
microphone and also you may notice that
i'm not in a place that is familiar to
you
and you may not be able to notice that
because my camera is way too close
and it it can't go any farther back you
may have noticed that there weren't many
videos this past week you may have
noticed a lot of things and if you
didn't notice you haven't been paying
attention
what have you been listening to
distractible have you been being
distracted by it
my life has been moving along and you
have not been paying attention to me
either way i recorded a lot of videos
they didn't survive
i don't even know if this one's gonna
survive so i'm playing
mighty flinger and i don't know if you
saw
the first episode because i don't know
if that one actually got saved i thought
it did but then
i haven't asked because i've been very
busy filming anyway
i'm gonna play it now and hope
and really hope that this is working
and if it's not gonna be a very big
problem
anyway i'm
i'm willing to bet that it has not saved
and i'm willing to bet that i'm going to
be starting over from the beginning and
it may seem like i'm an
amateur at this but i'm not i swear
you starting hello
well that didn't make much sense now did
it i was on
what are you doing oh
oh you did well it's not gonna make any
ah
hi i don't know where you've seen this
from
so i gotta go back down to the bottom
oh no oh
[Music]
oh
okay i made it back down to the bottom
which is really good and i'll tell you
why that's good
it's not good
but it's good for you guys because now
you get context of everything in this
game this is mighty flinger i don't know
if you've seen episode one of this
so i'm gonna assume that you didn't and
then my skill will be self-evident
i'm also playing on a couch i am not
lying
well not even a couch it's a chair i'm
playing this on a chair on a laptop on a
chair holding a microphone
trying to play this with a mouse that's
on an uneven surface
and it's one of those games where it's
kind of important to have a little bit
of precision about yourself
and uh you know what yeah i can't get
much precision about myself
if uh if i can't exactly uh uh
consistently mouse
uh
this is gonna take forever because i'm
all i'm all confident with my ability to
do this before because obviously i made
progress
man this microphone is heavy it's hard
to hold i don't want to hold it
i'm going to hold it i don't know it's
just it's sad you know you lose an
entire week an entire
week's worth of videos like i played
subnautica
i played a bunch of things i played more
of this game
i don't know how much of this game made
it i don't know if this episode of this
game is going to make it
i don't know what's happening i know
nothing
i know like nothing so i'm just going to
go into this
and i'm going to assume that everything
is fine because
everything is fine then everything is
totally meant to click
great is it recording it better be why
would it not
be recording in absolute
high quality because that was a problem
before my mic
broke i don't know if there's footage of
that
i bet it looked better than this i
haven't even gotten my lights set up
this is just a hotel lamp no this is
important i'm cutting myself
off before i go deeper off the end and
i'm gonna play this game
that you guys are here to watch me play
goodly
which is how i do things
god damn it okay hey
oh i haven't been talking about what i'm
going through or reading anything
because i'm
i should be operating on the assumption
that you guys have not seen any of this
oh whoa interesting
interesting oh whoo
whoo
damn it oh god i'm really gonna lose
this
i am really gonna lose this
[Music]
okay as you can see that i've got a lot
of skill and i know what i'm doing most
of the time
which
[Music]
shambles nailed that
because i'm a freaking huge
douchebag i don't know what i'm trying
to say about myself
probably good things i know there's a
way to get that there i don't feel like
doing it i know i can get here because
i've done it before
oh it's fine
nothing to worry about
okay i guess i could do that thing i
don't feel like it though
uh do i want to go that way now i can
show you guys how to
do it how a pro actually does it bam bam
just like that that's how pros do did
you know
just like that oh my god please do not
is there a way to care it's a way to
cancel a fling
because sometimes i don't do so good and
i would like to not
fall and die that would be ideal
[Music]
okay
okay so i know
i know we know i know we know or
i i'm conjecturing i'm guesstimating
that there's oh look there was a way
down here oh that's fascinating that's
so
fascinating anyway let me just
come on
[Music]
i also don't know if you guys have seen
this
already so i don't know where you know
i haven't shown you guys
what i'm doing or what i know oh my god
no oh my god no
my god
oh my god oh my god
i have to actually be quiet because i'm
in a hotel now i'm just
i'm not in a good mood guys i don't know
if you could tell that and this is
really an ass to hold i
i can't hook up my goddamn
boom arm i never realized what a job a
boom arm did and i don't have the normal
sandbag that i usually do am i even
still in frame
i don't know oh my god this is
so horrible it was horrible
this is literally i've never recorded in
worse scenarios than this
i am so goddamn privileged
i apologize i'm just a mess i'm sorry
guys i'm a
freaking mess there we go i did the dang
thing
i did it there's a fling ball here
whatever the inanimate object i actually
am
is why you know
that's just my question i really don't
understand why okay here we go
join perfect
i'm quite good at this knowing because
not too much
okay and then all i have to do is wait
until it gets to exactly where i need to
do i
i also know the webcam positioning and
zoom is very inconvenient for you lixian
but you're just gonna have to deal with
it there is no room for you in this box
so don't even try to get in here because
i can't deal with your sass right now so
don't even think about being sassy to me
because i'm not going to take it
not today
why'd you do that hey look it was all
jokes man i didn't mean it
i didn't have to move my ball
that's sorry just having a rough day
that's the most goofy thing i've ever
done not goofy like haha silly
i literally embodied goofy in that
moment okay
ah that was close
nice nice nice hey
[Music]
oh it's this dude that i've never
definitely never seen before
wow look at that oh that's cool
and new and interesting ooh what are
these things that i've never seen before
[Music]
guess i gotta go find out whoopsies
oh whoopsies whoa they disappear
all right everything so much i hate
today i hate i hate today i hate what
today is
it's just and my fans on my computer are
still
roiling like the most
fan you could ever have oh and this
uh i think i can actually just can't i
just
nope apparently not
[Music]
this is not a good time you know oh
catch me uh
i'm not having a good time guys you know
and i i don't mean
usually i like to be a beacon of
sunshine to you guys
usually i'm a beacon of sunshine usually
i'm like
just i'm glowing with positive energy
that's what i do that's who i
am everyone knows this about me shut up
if you don't think so but that's what i
am
today i'm just not feeling it i need
your guys's energy
to help build me back up also i might be
peaking the microphones
i'm setting the microphone down because
i just don't care anymore
i know that there's just a huge ass fan
in the way
guys it's also hot for some reason in
this hotel room
it's like the thermostat is locked why
would anybody
do that why would anybody do that why
would they lock the thermostat that's
the one
joy you get to have you get to control
the thermostat
no one tells you what to do they charge
enough for the room anyway why can't you
control the thermos
if i want it to be 61 degrees i'm gonna
make it 61 degrees but it's since
celsius over here so if i want to make
it like 16 degrees celsius i'm going to
make it 16 degrees celsius
you can't tell me what to do and how to
live my life
it's been a day you know actually the
day's been fine i really got nothing to
complain about i
i had a lovely morning i had lovely
everything all i'm complaining about is
literally just my recording setup is
slightly
not what i would want it to be that is
literally what's breaking me today
and that's really pathetic i know but i
need to have this moment
okay and so i've chosen my game of
choice
to be a game that is a little
aggravating and that's okay
it's perfectly logical don't think about
it too much
this is what i've chosen and what i've
chosen is perfectly logical to
me oh
hey perfectly logical to me
hello dude you're dead thank you um
i'm gonna go up here now and then i'm
gonna go over here i hope you guys can
hear me still
i bet you can maybe not over the roar of
the freaking
[Applause]
alienware you want to hook me up please
that'd be dope anybody want to hook me
up anybody
i'm literally willing to chill out for
anybody right now
and i guess i could just buy a laptop
easy enough look at me look at me
look at me looking look at me
oh god i remember this this is suck ass
this is suck ass 9000 ah this is suck
ass maybe i could just
maybe actually oh
close
yeah i think i can can bypass that
stupid little angular thing
yeah yeah definitely no oh
my god oh my oh my god
oh my god oh my god no ah just fall down
okay it's fine
problem solved okay cool cool
let's just go for it
why did i say just go for it why would i
say just go for it it definitely was
not the time to just go oh my god
okay i'm so stupid
nice okay we've nailed this now we have
most certainly nailed this
nailing it is what i've done and now i'm
gonna do this
cool
cool cool
[Music]
i did it okay cool this is going so well
can you guys tell that you guys tell how
well this is going
okay hey this is great
oh my god no
can i complain some more i wasn't even
centered on camera can i complain some
more
i just i i really
why is my fan still blowing so
loudly
it's so it's so loud i
look hey hi
i the only reason that this is so crap
is because it's very late at night
i didn't have a lot of time to set up
anything there's no quality in this
and i know that but lixian here to make
it all better
he's gonna give you one reason why you
should have any sort of pity on me
right about now it's your chance
lexington here you go
go on speak right into the microphone
tell them how you really feel about me
come on don't be shy
[Music]
great i don't know this is just such
chaos please i don't know
i don't know what to do anyway they're
coming for me
they're coming together
[Music]
subscribe and like the video and comment
what your favorite moment of this video
was for you which is now your favorite
video
elixir is still cut to black on that
moment but now keep this going
this is good stuff definitely don't cut
away from this you want to keep this
going as long as possible
[Music]
you